hey everybody what's going on welcome to
stream Coco yeah sorry need up so I so
tighten the camera there and scare all
the little kids watching I'm face like a
muppet and the temperament um different
how's everybody going how's it going
welcome everyone we're very excited
because we're gonna be playing the brand
new game donut County today and we've
announced right I can say this I always
worry about getting in trouble of
announcing things cuz I'm like screech
you know like an Saved by the Bell
all right just something tells me a
secret and I just immediately just spit
it out we're going to Japan next week so
we're very very very excited so if
anybody from Japan is watching hello and
what can't wait to see you soon and also
if you've been to Japan or just like
Japan or have heard of Japan and want a
wikipedia Japan tell us things to do in
Japan let us know very exciting hey
Ratan how's it going Sandra June 8 Anne
Athan mad Rae Frozone Conan is a good
guy actually he's amazing and he doesn't
just it's not just because he pays me to
say that he doesn't actually pay me so
here we go let's play so this game I'm
super pumped
I actually pre-ordered it I love games
like this that kind of are a little bit
different Katamari Damacy is another
game that game is where you just try to
roll around sticking things to a giant
ball in this game I think you play a
whole Ben Esposito great job making it
cool looking here hey what's up for an
tanveer frozen is here oh what am i
coming into work oh okay let's reply
[Music]
huh
by the way huh it's not a giant phone in
our hand are we just really small look
how big that phone is the honking man
the honk of dawn no boy all right I get
the idea that we want to get a story
here going but also I just want to be a
hole yeah you know had like a whole
continent and eeeh would be awesome I'd
love to go to India
there's Conan of a console at home Steve
at Steve 94 I know he plays minecraft
his kids are into video games I'm not
sure exactly which ones I'm not sure if
he has a console or not he has consoles
in his office here but I'm not sure if
he has them out certified loaf I'm gonna
start calling people loaves I do like
when people I love like a insult like an
ohm I God okay I do like when people say
things like you're a loaf or you're a
mad lad I like stuff they're like like
kind of insults but not really oh look
at this okay this feels like a game that
I should play on PC but and here it
comes all the PC people want to see
Conan and Jordan so do i Chris so do I
ooh we're gonna crawl out the window
doughnut County oh yeah look at this Oh
Ben you're gonna have to play this game
this is very satisfying already you can
suck everything down that oh this is
great oh and you know what as you suck
more things down your hole gets bigger
there's so many jokes to be made here so
inappropriate
I can't I can't do it yet oh this is so
fun
oh wait I want to get that guy in my
hole get in my hole dude I could trip
him oh oh he's almost in my hole get in
my hole oh Jesus
Oh No Oh get back in this you know
what's hilarious is we share walls with
a bunch of offices and I'm just gonna be
screaming get in my hole the entire hour
and here we go go to themed restaurants
alright sherlyn like what what's a good
theme donut County man you're an odd
duck
my favorite video game of all time peach
lover that's tough oh my god oh I see
that was the guy who was honking oh my
god which is this raccoon of crazy hole
creating powers I don't trust raccoons
by the way I know No raccoons are
nature's criminal first of all they've
got like oh oh interesting you think
that alright then how what about this
best raccoons have opposable thumbs
which means they can use tiny little
tiny little knives switch blades and
stuff they could crack safes yeah they
can't I a raccoon could put on a little
stethoscope and then crack a tiny little
safe with its opposable thumbs
okay telling you they're made to be
nature's bandits they eat trash okay I'm
not paying attention this story I just
want to be a whole go see a samurai
sword be made that'd be amazing is this
sponsored by Tonka Donuts or Krispy
Kreme I don't know but if Ben Esposito
the creator of this game didn't get
money from a donut company he's a fool
what's happening here oh it's a broken
drone
can you co co-host to Peter olds ask
well talk to amazed about that I think
that was pretty cool laughs and you're
off yeah
last night we had Andy Ross he was nice
enough to donate a lot of a bunch of
money you destroy the entire town whoa
what happened 999 feet below donut
County oh my god is this a flash-forward
this is everything we've sucked down
into our whole whole lap whoa
this is gonna get crazy I'm the victim
see classic raccoon thinking Coco yeah
there we go
just let's just like him that's a Kona
looks like without makeup by the way
green and snout II do I care about
League ma I'm not sure what lignin is I
care about Lego mints because that's
helps me move around
what is it somebody explain what alig
missed me turn away from what ii have no
idea what this is
McGary for a VP this is a game called
donut County came out today very excited
about it you play a raccoon that with an
app on your phone can open up holes and
now we're all stuck underground these
are gonna be another thing where we
shoot back up
Potter's Rock now wait a second that
don't it's been like half eaten what's
going on here
press X to deploy hole oh this is this
is really I could see getting really
into this coming from after work putting
a bunch of stuff in my hole yeah exactly
it's a bit of a puzzle kind of figure
out what goes in then I want you to play
the next level get this skull out of
here
damn yeah it's kind of like a puzzler
supposed to be good I wonder if this is
on mobile oh here we go
Oh see this is what I like because
remember that game Katamari Damacy I was
saying I talking about earlier where you
basically get in there get in my hole
were you an amazing game I think it's
like for the PlayStation 2 ooh this is a
similar thing where the scale changes as
you get bigger uh-oh I do feel bad about
putting people in my hole yeah let's not
disturb the pottery yet maybe I can just
get her pottery down in one thing so
it's not really I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Oh disappointed it's so disappointed me
how do I do this though have to get this
pillow off
she's just disappointed she resists
get in there yes now there there's your
stupid pottery by the point of the
scheme rat rats Ratan oh no oh no I
don't want to break those things oh oh
because it makes my whole girl left can
I get that pool in the hole I don't
think I'm supposed to be breaking this
stuff I think that's the point is like
you know a little bit stunts do as much
this kid is gonna be scarred for life
watching all this stuff getting sucked
into the hole oh you don't select the
pool it is this the hole that ko needs
to get rid of entered the Brico brick
everything a venue has anybody played
this game by the way today it came out
today yeah but maybe some people got it
early this raccoon is kind of a dick
it's a lot of destruction for what oh oh
no I'm trapped
also my holes on fire oh no my the holes
burning up oh god am I about to ruin
this level can I do anything else no
buttons do anything uh guys my hole is
burning this is never gonna get old
saying the whole thing theme restaurants
prison hospital
vampire cafe I don't want to go to a
vampire cafe hello be easy take selfies
cuz nobody get in your way my holes on
fire humongous fungus
where's Conan in his office I don't know
if he's gonna come I asked if you come
down he's gonna come down this game is
very stress relieving but now I'm stuck
bubble I'm a ranked nine-hole driver
wait how do I get out of here is there
any way to my my holes trapped oh you
know what I have to do oh I see when the
fire goes in then you have to put it
underneath the thing and then the hot
air will make them shoot up but I have
to quit unfortunately is there like a
restart
I hope my progress hasn't been totally
autosave it's badger he found you run
put some welcome to the balloon so his
exergaming oh no we got to go back to
this skip skip skip skip skip skip skip
skip skip skip don't make me watch this
whole thing again what's up dog under
the balloon a true gamer says wesley van
that's right only true gamers get stuck
on like the second level i don't know
what my favorite game is my favorite
couple games for the last year my
favourite most recent game besides donut
county which is amazing press x to
deploy a whole alright here we go is I'm
really liking dead cells lately is
really fun very addictive ah so my
favorite games of all time on the Last
of Us of course I love hell-blade since
we sacrifice it's really fun if you play
it on headphones inside was an amazing
game everybody should play inside that
game is super fun but don't read
anything about it it's better if you
don't know going in what it is there we
go done yeah those are good I love braid
braid is a huge loop that huge favorite
of mine I like games that like donut
County which we're playing right now I
like games that show you something
different like everybody's done the Call
of Duty shooter games everyone's done
that this is great like been Esposito's
made an amazing game you're a whole it's
incredible
it's super fun relaxing and honestly
kind of challenging I mean I've had to
just replay the second level already
but yeah super simple and I love games -
you're like man why didn't I think of
that this is such a simple fun game
sorry you got to go in the hole gotta go
from that hole here your pottery get it
all in the hole put it in the hole yeah
you should definitely be ah tomorrow if
you haven't already yeah I love Katamari
one of my favorite games
Suton and categories super satisfying
but also really frustrating and
challenging everybody in everybody in
this hole that's a great question we're
playing on PlayStation I would imagine
it's on PC am I looking forward to death
stranding ooh very much so I can't wait
I love kojima a huge fan death stranding
is gonna be fantastic I'm fair it looks
insane and crazy and super fun here we
go
that's right go balloon go try to escape
my hole my smoking hole it's a lot of
gas coming out of my home guys now we're
in this is great holy crap there goes
the pool this is awesome guys this is so
a meet relaxing
this is incredibly satisfying I just
everything goes in the hole man what a
great game yeah so true as as his life
as his donut county oh oh no oh no no I
feel terrible
no we killed our friend just like every
every level ends just like everyone he
getting splat trash' pedia
this music kinda reminds me a little toe
jam and earl who it's full of spiders
that's what a flying I didn't need to
know that it's a free house don't let it
get wet okay come here if you want to
get yelled at by coyotes coffee rules
I'm not sure what I'm doing here
tracks you from cows I guess can make
your own bones at home alright I don't
good joke good joke ready good joke
ready have a garbage day oh that's fun
that's got to be a t-shirt we're the
guests in the show today we have Bob
Newhart Bob Newhart glaziers hilarious
Bob Newhart if you haven't seen his King
Kong bit is hilarious have you seen
these bits from olden time okay he did a
lot of really cool stuff where he would
call it would be a fake phone call so he
would be like one of his famous pizzas
like he's talking on the phone or the
phone and so it's kind of like a
one-sided phone conversation but the
reveals of what he's talking about or
really great so it's like one is I think
and he's in the lobby and someone's
calling cuz King Kong is on the Empire
State Building and he's in the lobby
then first he was like how can I help
you
what's that you know like it's really
great I got a chuckle from Jason
O'Malley over there oh it's a snake oh
no oh I think I'm gonna have to capture
stuff with my whole like my snake what's
going on with the there's also a
spotlight do I have to stay out of the
light this gate what if this game gets
like super hard and creepy I'm not sure
I don't really do I want to stay out of
the spotlight it looks like it's not
doing anything
you kick how do you stop a hole anyway
what if they do if they find me in a
spotlight doesn't matter and apparently
I'm learning if those cacti are all full
of spiders which is very disturbing the
last thing you want to hear
also is this time there's no time limit
right does feel like oh here's something
I learned you ever see interstellar
what but you gotta see it it's great
well then I was gonna say something but
it's gonna ruin every so for yet chicken
yeah those chickens are gonna definitely
get in my hole I'm gonna put those
chicken I'm gonna put those chickens in
my hole so hard here we go yeah ah whoa
oh no oh no snake danger what's
happening wait what is this
now this this is now getting a little
perverse oh damn
double double entendre we're going like
triple entendre this one what is
happening oh look oh I can knock him off
then yeah like I can push this chicken
on a swing what am I supposed to do now
bat this chicken around yeah your
chicken
I don't know what to do
I do not do them to an eternal life of
falling that's true
oh here we go wait maybe this is
something how could I put stuff in my
hole if this stupid
oh whoa snake dangers that read well you
know what I have to do I think I just
have to keep annoying these chickens so
much that then they something happens
right there we go Oh snake dangers at
maximum snake dangers what they used to
call me on the streets oh my god wait
it's full of snakes the thing is full of
snakes so now we got to get all these
snakes in the hole this is dead what
made this game new when you're putting a
bunch of snakes in a hole you know
you're doing you know what I'm saying
but wait if we're putting both the
snakes and the chickens in the hole that
means the chickens are all dead a scheme
is a secret darkness to it and I kind of
like it so many good nicknames secret
darkness snake danger bye enjoy your
snakes oh my god huge gaping mobile
internet is painful yeah sorry raccoons
and holes it wasn't a cat tail Queen it
was a snake tail now this guy's falling
forever
I feel terrible but we're almost to rank
10 and that's all that matters
there's a snake in my boot exactly is it
doughnut hole a doughnut no it's a donut
hole it's a much get there here
munchkins are delicious all right look I
do love this I love this story but we're
not gonna we're not doing this story
right now I'm sorry we're just not gonna
do we got salt pepper salt and pepper
down here
well me and pepper feuding again so I
moved my trailer to MIT River who took a
liking to this
yeah yep a bird made for liking I was
admiring this bird till I was hit with a
hunger I started doing it by weighing
the doughnut count yeah oh I see this is
the doughnut County app that's screwing
everybody up then the whole game oh
they're all telling their tails
I didn't they're all telling their tails
in the future about how they all ended
up down in the hole and we are the hole
guys were the enemy you either you
either die a hero or live long enough to
see yourself become the villain another
Christopher Nolan adage have you seen
Dark Knight there we go oh my god oh you
little pug by the way these fish would
be clearly dead by now flopping around
like that
[Music]
come on get in the hole get in the hole
buddy eyyy
[Music]
you know all those in the campfire are
the one have been swallowed by the whole
oh look at this you know what this is
good because we need Oh No
oh no I filled it with water oh crap how
do we get the water out of the hole no
the fish will put the fish in the thing
do the fish drink the water nope oh I
put the stork does though yep that's it
[Music]
but we don't want to suck up the stork
because the stork is what's gonna help
us damn it
there we go
not yet so close are we eventually gonna
be able to suck up all the water oh damn
oh wow throw things around here yeah all
right well that's good we made a little
pathway
another Fischer popping out of the water
I love the Lord for this game can't wait
for the books this is actually based on
Lord of the Rings Return of the King
this is uh that the hole is actually
Aragorn and this is all clean he's come
to reclaim his that is his rightful
place his property and this is all of
saurons forces a lot of people don't
know that about yeah these are this is
an O oh my god exactly how cool is the
co-star
wait did you see the movies yeah okay oh
there we go now see that's not good
physics sorry bird you gotta get oh the
bird doesn't go in well oh well plot
twist oh maybe we have to know now the
bird goes in there we go
Conan's my favorite uncle oh my god
what's an he's your uncle
yeah if you want a bamm-bamm the words a
and hole you probably shouldn't play
this game the hole is a monster
we are the monster I love this needs to
be a shirt I'm gonna say right now have
a garbage day don't you say that garbage
isn't necessarily a bad thing
it's delicious a-and it's just kind of
you know it's like we all make garbage
we just don't want to talk about it you
know it's our hidden shame garbage is
our oh oh my god what is happening these
I do see the I'd love to see like a lot
of merchandise of this I would
definitely buy like a plush hole so glad
I read the volumes and watch the movies
to get to learn of the Rings in there
you go
other guys gonna left fine you take the
mother bird and left the babies to fend
for themselves it's not my fault your
forehead really as big as it looks in
the thumbnail yes I think I have a
pretty large forehead let's get in there
let's get in there real quick how big is
that forehead I mean it's pretty big I
don't know do you think I have a
normal-sized forehead how big is your
forehead well yours is covered by hair
mine's like this mine's like this big
weight a whole lot if your head is this
big yeah we're your first hair so I'm
gonna say your so your hat from your hat
your face is this big all right and then
your forehead is this big so what's that
like
all right I'm gonna do a hole this is a
thumb is basically like an inch all
right so you see what I'm not gonna
touch your face 1 2 3 4 5 6
I'm gonna go 6 and a half inches your
forehead is about 2 inches so what's
that 2 2 to 6 this is 1/3 1/3 Jeffords
baby
now we'll do it online all right ready 1
2 3 4 5 oh my god 6 7 8 9 and then let's
say 1 2 3 4 so 4 nights
so my forehead is bigger is very large
thank you for pointing out something I
can hate about myself again or not that
is actually half my face Jesus oh my god
I'm having an existential crisis why of
course it is half as big as my face wait
that's true look at this
well now I have to stream for another
half hour knowing that my forehead is
half the size of my head thank you
whoever said that and that's that's
exactly what I needed
on this Wednesday to feel better about
myself damn it I have played Detroit
become human quite a bit and it's
awesome oh my god I'm not happy about
this let's deploy where are you you play
this don't play this little X and then
you just hold it around deploy a whole
Beth this place you never played this is
great oh yeah oh oh the whole Fox is
watching you
now remember oh you know what I think
you can cook that corn if you get the
fire in your hole yeah I'm not handsome
Koffler thank you
also I'm back on the dating app so let's
not talk about that oh wait oh no you
sucked up all the yeah okay okay well
maybe if you put the fire in it it'll
pop out popcorn
yeah oh there's one up there there's one
up there there's some stuff yeah um man
maybe that should be my thing on the
dating apps my forehead is half as big
as my face yeah I agree
Kona needs to play this I asked him to
come down but I think he's in a meeting
maybe do you need to suck up the corn
[Music]
get that corn oh there's some stuff down
here in the foreground can't get it try
getting that little rock up there that
that'll give you enough
Conan's asleep yeah he wakes up at 1:00
p.m. every day I try to get that fighter
oh look at you it's amazing yeah yeah
popcorn
yes oh here comes the birds yes this is
great
oh my god this game is so fun oh and
then you get your whole gets to get even
bigger yeah oh my god but now we're
gonna cook the would've like cooked your
like chicken breasts oh now we're
dooming the Fox to death you realize
that we're gonna burn him alive in this
hole
again chats are little kozko okay Red
Dead Redemption - oh my god I would love
to do that for close game would be so
fun
get in the hole so you don't you just
want to scream get in the hole no hole
jokes allowed mama tried Jeff Berner
mama tried to make somebody whose
forehead wasn't half as big as their
face oh yeah see this is where it gets
great you just throw it all in the hole
I want to do this to my life just put my
life in a giant hole yeah oh my god
don't even joke that'd be so amazing
sorry fiery death for you
this game is I gotta say it's really
cute but it is really dark we're burning
everything alive and a giant this is
like the opposite of Katamari Damacy
that's true you're right kooky man
Beth is killing it I agree it's a genius
idea when you guys start live streaming
about three years ago we've done a 24
hour live stream for years
get in the hole deep boy where'd I get
the t-shirt I don't know I got a line
somewhere t public maybe now there's a
place called screened with a K screen
comm that has a bunch of dumb here you
owe me this great job alright where
there is a good story and I don't want
to crap on the story that's great but we
don't nobody wants to see text on screen
where I say the simpsons episode of the
mini black hole I've never seen that one
Conan does have a big forehead what do
you think his ratio is is he is he like
me we're both freaks
it is really disturbing what I can't
quite look directly at my own face
because it's just horrifying oh my god
there's a lot of water here okay here we
go
oh oh look there's two people trying to
get lucky up there oh I'm gonna ruin
their date
nothing I like better than a good [ __ ]
block oh yeah yep don't worry there's
just a growing hole sucking everything
just listen to the pleasant music don't
worry about the darkness below that I'm
sending everyone to this game has a lot
of like religious undertones there's
nothing you can do the afterlife is
gonna take you you know the hole comes
for everybody at a certain point in the
darkness a giant void blackness of which
there is no escape even even if you're
in that pen you think here you think
you're safe from my hole you're not oh
no oh you know what I've been this guy
come over here and get it for me right
come now to eat this Carrie unplug my
hole hey hey WTF the podcast more like a
5 head ok jpn you don't need to pile on
that's what I do here my hole is plugged
[Music]
cut the 10 minutes from time plays
pressing his thumb up caught his face I
am I'm going to you by the way I'll
probably use the tape measure cuz I
don't want to touch him because he's
like he sweats like a weird acidic what
we do here
damnit
oh you know what I wonder if I can go
over here somehow I kind of get over
this I need to start over this game is
actually kind of hard I'm not gonna lie
deceptively hard and I'm sure that's as
many times before but when I cover your
favorite NES games mr. poo poo John well
that's a good question I really love
Ninja Gaiden I played that forever when
I was a kid I'm have to restart this
level man is that terrible
I gotta restart I care it screwed me um
Ninja Gaiden was awesome weird some
other amazing ones Super Mario 2 is one
of my favorites super Mario's great -
Mario 3 are fantastic with - for some
reason all those turn ups play that a
lot my deeply emotional man yes clearly
do you see how ripped up I am about my
forehead it's actually I'm joking about
it on the stream but that knows I'm
gonna go back to the office and just
talk about my dad or head the entire
time little lu lu er the blue rabbit out
oh yoooo Adrian is saying our sour sauce
he's saying I didn't need to restart a
cone evident which channel is so lol he
doesn't even know what twitch is that's
true he just he just twitches as a
person he's been on the stream though
bunch we'll get him on a stream know
where this game is amazing it's
incredibly satisfying again we're
playing you guys are joining us for
playing doughnut hole for the ps4 it's
incredibly fun it's kind of the opposite
of Connemara Demasi but fun in the same
way and it's got it's a little
challenging it's kind of like a puzzle
game and I love games like this like
games that that show you something new
it's fantastic I highly recommend this
game it's cheap
I think I would guess it's for all
platforms it should be now how why is
this rabbit gonna come out oh I get it I
have to kind of make him go around the
thing all right I see okay so come on I
see we kind of got to have them come
over here right oh yeah I see he'll hop
over here we go here we go hop a pull
thing buddy
hop up a little thing to your doom
that's right only the darkness cuz yeah
get in the hole everybody goes in the
hole man there we go yeah now you're
dead sorry
that's your doom sorry guys oh oh oh my
god this cave is dirty they made more
money than her I love it I mean I guess
it is kind of dark down there pretty
private although not really because of
all the things you play yeah yeah they
just maybe put on like a weird sex show
in the hole oh here we go now we're just
scooping it all up scoop it all up
everything goes everything goes in the
hole everything goes
everybody goes in the hole
oh my god what's happening this hole is
really man is a sexy hole up I'm seeing
two more lovers going in the hole I
don't kill them by accident
get in the hole bro gross this is just
gross they're having sex in the hole
Thank You snake Barbie hey miss tits uh
here it comes
ah get back in the hole get back in the
hole everybody yeah jeez [ __ ] it Sims
it's like an existential Sims is there
life in the hole apparently there is
there they are
the couple still got his legs crossed
that kind of really have to go to the
bathroom
orgy yeah it's an orgy hole apparently
choking sheep don't say sexy hole ever
again I mean it is kind of a sexy hole
have a garbage day is there any clueless
gamers coming soon please you cut in
Jordan make make one episode oh yes
we're going to Japan next week which is
very exciting so you know we are gonna
be out of the country thank you for all
your tips of telling us what to do in
Japan apparently a lot of good themed
cafes there I'm excited about the food
I'm really excited I love Japanese food
is one of my favorites
I hope you're cured of your leg ma I
guess so I don't understand what's the
lignin thing might be something dirty
all right fair enough trying for a baby
or just woo-hooing I don't know bear ski
here we go now see this is like a nice
peaceful night everybody's money no
business and here's this hole up to its
old dirty tricks all right all right now
we got some flames let's light this BBQ
up am I gonna cook this bird I guess I
can't yeah Oh cook the bird okay light
on fire oh my god oh no oh this is
terrible I don't want to open that thing
as it's full of spiders and the spiders
are scary this is like this whole is
awful this whole is it demon maybe this
is like maybe I've been sent well you
know by like the powers that be to like
get revenge like if you haven't lived a
good life the whole will come and get
you oh my god this is pure madness
Jesus this crow is like an agent of
death
oh no I don't want to start a forest
fire California is like burning this is
terrible
all right here we go yeah
everything goes in really burned that
laptop right up didn't we
all right oh my god this is terrible I
guess now I gotta set this car on fire
because that's what I'm supposed to do
yeah oh my god this is terrible
this is like this this gets darker and
darker by the way pretty soon we're
gonna go to like like the somebody owes
the whole money we're gonna like go
extort we just become like a bouncer I
like an enforcer for the underworld
that's where it's going I don't know it
is fun that everything goes in the hole
and I'll say that this is extremely yep
fiery halt there's a cream for that by
the way if your hole is burning there's
a cream for that I just want to put that
out there who is MJ Michael Jackson
clearly hey John Rambo jr. or as I call
you jrj Kona's should go be weird and
lanky in a foreign country and have them
laugh at him for being weird and lanky
clearly you've never seen a cone without
borders oh please we're on it that's
that's what it is it's a hold of hell
that's true this is a hell hole the hole
gets you
you know that's a good point Federation
oh gee the hole gets you but you can
still make love within the hole so it is
possible the holes not totally evil cuz
the hole does bring people together what
airport I'm not sure Jupiter I have no
idea fire in the hole oh my god I can't
thank you David Martin I can't believe I
took this long to figure out that joke
worse i deploy my whole oh it's been
deployed sorry you know what this is
what the hole should be used for it
cleaning up garbage this is great
imagine how easy it would be where's all
this garbage by lotion I don't know it's
terrible we're gonna fix that Beth you
and I also why is there a cactus on
pavement oh oh this dudes lighting off
fireworks what oh we got a oh I'm gonna
get these birds let me shoot him with a
rocket wait for it to light
bye-bye birdie gonna shoot off or what I
guess I gotta wait for it this if I try
to suck him up oh oh I see I have to
wait for it to light there we go and
then it goes in here boom pow now you're
in the hole that's right now you're mine
this hole is nefarious this is a
nefarious evil hole this hole is
shockingly bad yeah we're gonna get this
- check this out oh man oh snap also
terrible place for a picnic that's not
safe
get ready boom we're literally going
after this guy to try to kill him and
put him in the hole damn it yeah yep
that's right you're dead now oh my god
yeah that his hand hope there's a doctor
down there in the hole oh now we're on
fire I guess we could we got more
popcorn going on car gets yeah that's
right oh my god it's crazy sorry
everybody goes in the hole now get in
the hole
everyone's going in the hole oh oh oh my
god is there cutscene
oh it's Coco hey look at that oh thank
yous ACK the Trina's you to say substr
hey ro yo yo be good yeah it's a smart
hole it's a smart dangerous hole I saw
Kumar we're playing donut County it's
amazing the idea is you are a hole and
you are have a garbage day and and
you're sucking things down into the hole
we can't decide if the hole I feel like
has bad intentions then there's a whole
story that's going on that we're not
really watching where all these people
have been sucked into the hole so I
think it's like an evil app or something
yeah
there's a great book by Jonathan Lethem
called because that's what people want
to hear about on a video game stream
clips I call as she climbed across the
table about a guy who creates a hole to
another dimension and he names it lack
and his girlfriend falls in love with
the hole it's great it's weird and great
how did I recommend Jonathan leaf limits
as she climbed across the tea he gets
jealous of a whole oculus gamer
spider-man Red Dead Redemption to her
kingdom are three I've never played
Kingdom Hearts spider-man and red Denver
nation to look amazing
should I play Kingdom words what is that
game okay fair enough it's got all the
Disney characters in it hey sue Yosh
what's up
she had Conan to play the big foot game
on Steam what's the big foot game Jeff
burner being a hole and doing whole
things just holding around the hole is a
personality yeah the hole is a pretty
large dick I'm gonna say pretty sassy
hole oh man oh look at all these little
chameleons this is fun
sorry chameleons you got to die get in
the hole bye sorry music I don't know
it's like magnetic fields
I think it is magnetic field everybody
everything goes in the hole sorry
everything goes in the hole guys gotta
get in this hole get in the hole get in
the hole hole it's not big enough okay
I mean you'll all be together in the
darkness of the afterlife actually the
hole isn't the afterlife it's just
literally it's a hole - babbling yeah
it's a hole into a cavern so everyone is
gonna be fine anybody who's worried
about this hole interesting how do I do
this no wait a second
there's other things here
ah there we go I was gonna say I
couldn't get that guy in the hole I
guess you just gotta oh look how they
try to struggle welcome to my hole
welcome to my hole that's flaw Flo
Rida's new song
I bet though if you tried to make a song
called welcome my hole it probably
teamed pretty obscene that's the thing
if you were I will say if you're trying
to explain this game to somebody aren't
you just go and you put everything in
your hole
gets a little much you must capture
Bigfoot in the woods and you have one
life oh yeah that's true
it's County though I think donut
country's gonna be the sequel no I think
I was supposed to do something over here
with these things can I make these
things fall over I guess he's going in
he's drying his gloves
what hey there's people doing exercise
that's fun it does right everything goes
in the hole get in the hole by the way
he should have cleaned all this trash up
how many tires do you have over there
yep straight that's a great shape to go
in a hole there he goes yep can we make
rank 10 in 10 minutes I think we can
just joining us today we have Bob
Newhart Nikki Glaser and yeah Brad
Wenzel
very excited we're going to Japan next
week anybody's watching what time is it
in Japan right now it's 16 hours ahead
right so it's 12 to mean it's almost 1 +
4 6 5 a.m. 5 a.m. what - when we go to
that part of the that part of the world
your body is just like all right like
when we went to like the Middle East
it's so crazy and same thing with Korea
it's so crazy that your body's just like
alright I guess I'm just off yeah it's
almost like yeah it's almost too crazy
for any kind of you know any kind of oh
okay alright that's gross
that's nice that's gross you saw that
right you guys saw that right a guy
stroking his chicken yes you guys saw
that this game is filthy Vicki this
isn't just coincidence that all these
things are happening this game is really
is super it's secretly super dirty and I
love it okay it's not secret but I mean
you wouldn't think about this being yeah
we're pulling out of our bag
we're tugging at our back sorry
the game is making me say these things
understand what's happening
if to get this guy he's like you know
please no please Oh eggs what is that
what's going on also I also let me just
say if this is his house wouldn't he
have a raccoon sized toilet so he's
pooping at someone else's why did he
break into another person's house and
use the toilet yeah this is too much and
they misspelled too
oh my god yeah holy [ __ ] that's a hole
it's natural that's how you milk the
chickens on your farm she's pip Johnson
Thank You pip
potty positivity you're right we should
be positive about our potty
oh I can buy stuff I have a hundred and
ten oh it's a whole upgrade yeah whole
upgrade and I guess energy drinks I
don't know no let's not let's just get
her whole upgrade I'm saving up for the
beanbag chair oh look at this whoa our
hole has a catapult oh my god we could
shoot stuff back out of the hole this is
great oh my god I love this just when
you thought it was safe not to hole oh
you know what we can do
oh we could shoot that back oh no oh we
got the chicken out oh that's what's
loaded up our catapult up there on the
upper left so now we could shoot a
chicken way up oh here we go I got it we
do this
then we shoot our chicken up yeah oh no
I did it the wrong way anyway I got a
bunch of strawberries for no reason
alright get it let's load up our chicken
into the hole oh no way here's what we
have to do we have to shoot it up wow
this game about a hole got way more
complicated yep
by chicken this is amazing how long we
stay in Japan I don't know it's a good
question oh my god this guy this is
disgusting what's happening here I bet
we have to or if you hit that lever you
think are do we put you sweep oh okay we
got a watermark wait should we try to
shoot it up over there hey what happened
our catapult
oh now we're loaded up I see
I don't understand uh yeah I think
you're right we have to hit that level
right
oh that's just 103 oh now we need oh now
he's gonna shoot out three I bet Jesus
God
oh yeah this is great look at how all
these eggs in our hole oh my god this is
insane I'm worried about how big this
hole is gonna get just go forever yep
that's right get in my hole perfect
everything goes in the hole get in that
hole get in the hole yep that guy look
that's what you get for stroking of
chicken creep at least he wasn't choking
if that's true I think I think how many
how many more minutes we have three four
minutes I think we can get to level 10
dry rooster in the hole as Conan played
alien isolation a sake is not but that's
a great game next time he comes into
tuned cocoa we should have been playing
only nice lady game is scary as hell but
also like I mean Conan doesn't hat with
that how is oh my god fast approaches
also like Conan I'm not sure has human
emotions so maybe you wouldn't be scared
he'd just be like oh there's the alien
whereas I'd be like oh you've seen I
played that a lot of my own stream and I
literally week it's it makes me sad
I didn't think called dinner in a video
game and instead of alien isolation it
was alien rice elation and we made
risotto and played an alien isolation
and I screamed oh we got a lot of bees
honey nut now every now I'm just
thinking of everything is dirty
cereal yeah hey do you want to play this
level you sure it's fine
oh there's honey in our poll don't can I
just say something I think we've got a
sticky hole I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
really sorry I'm sorry Beth he's disgust
with this whole thing
feathers calling HR as we speak
she's been texting with HR the entire
time she's like save me yeah I think we
have to release the bees right we got
some smoke we have a honeycomb here Oh
gotcha oh now we have to shoot right we
got to shoot this up to trap the bees or
something oh we got the Frog here let's
shoot them up and see what happens yeah
oh do frogs frogs eat bees and reload
things guys do front somebody Google
this I'm too busy putting things in my
hole who eats bees by the way do bees
have any predators I guess bees and
wasps hate each other actually you know
what I read this really crazy thing
which was this is true bees to kill a
wasp bees will surround the wasp in a
giant ball with their wings on the
inside and they flap their wings so fast
it burns the wasp alive that's a real
thing how awesome is that nature guys
it's brutal
georgeous Lansky has no human emotions
that's true it's been fun later bear ski
please photo Jordan that's a specific
breed in Japan not a puzzle I'm not sure
what you're talking about got a lot of
honeycombs got a lot of honey going on
gonna get our we got to deploy our frog
here oh we're saving our boy here oh my
god whoa the frogs getting big by the
way oh my god that's like a bear size
frog I'm worried this frog he's gonna
get too big for our hole I think so what
if he does the same all right let's make
our hole little bit bigger I feel like
he's gonna eat the guy oh this game is
horrifying geez got him though did we
get the level 10 No so close all right
well we'll have to get him next time
guys have a garbage day have a garbage a
happy hump day make sure to watch your
show tonight got Bob Newhart Nikki
Glaser and and the Brad Wenzel he's the
best Brad whistles the best watch for
Brad who cares about Bob and Nikki watch
for watch for Brad thank you guys for
joining us we will not see you next week
because I'll be in Japan so make sure
you keep an eye on Team Coco comms
Instagram and Twitter Conan O'Brien and
of course our Facebook page yeah you
might be watching this right now on
Facebook so make sure you're following
please and Twitter for all things team
Coco and Japan and if you're in Japan
we'll see you guys soon see you guys
later bye